[Musique]
bran hook angle look an e-book come here
you could do the carousel to switch and
wrap
[Applaudissements]
- 20 % 160 Je veux juste m'occuper de
ma grand-mère peut-être faire du shopping de temps
en temps quand j'étais un  gamin j'ai toujours
voulu travailler avec des animaux j'étais proche de
ces gars de Wall Street tu vois ce que nous
avons fait à ce pays j'ai volé à
tout le monde les gens qui travaillent dur ont
tout perdu et pas un de ces connards n'est
allé en prison
le jeu est truqué et il le fait  ne pas
récompenser les gens qui respectent les règles,
c'est comme braquer une banque sauf que vous obtenez
les clés êtes-vous dans ce sont
les emplois de mes collègues s'il vous plaît et si quelqu'un
appelle les flics et dit ce que j'ai dépensé
cinq mille dollars dans un club de strip-tease
envoyer de l'aide
nous  're famille maintenant
une famille avec de l'argent quand diriez-vous
que les choses sont devenues incontrôlables
[Musique]
alors le gars est revenu trois fois de plus
parce qu'il a dû aimer ça
[Musique]
nous n'avons rien fait de mal vous savez
Tony ne laissera pas ça arriver, je vais lui envoyer un
texto qui lui a donné  son téléphone vous
[Musique]